Mark?
It's Wade.
Heyyyy Mark.
I came all the way out here to see you!
I missed you.
You wanna hang out?
Yeah, Wade.
That's why I flew you to L.A.
Get in here, you freaking weirdo.
Hey guys!
Guess who decided to stop buy and not be a total
creeper weirdo at my doorstep.
Wade's here!
Hey guys!
Hey, Wade! How you doing?
I'm good, How are you doing?
???? [talking over each other]
That's good to hear..
It is a lot stronger than I remember
Anyway,
Bob and Cyndago are gonna be here tomorrow.
And we're gonna be able to go and have a lot of fun
and make a lot of cool games-Press your button
And then we're gonna be making videos all week long.
Game play, sketch comedy, you name it, we-
It's stronger-I just replaced the batteries.
That's not a good thing
So anyway, Bob and Cyndago are both going to be here tomorrow.
And they're gonna be joining us for more games
even more fun games. Even more f-
And we're gonna be doing it for your entertainment.
So, stay tuned for a week full of fun.
Oh! Also, did you know that I got pranked?
No, I didn't.
Yeahhhh
MagicOfRahat-...???
We just had a grand ole time playing video games so you-
Why'd you press it again?
I don't know-I just-I don't know!
It was my turn!
I just don't know!
I gotta do it twice now.
Let me press it.
OWWW! WHY?! WHY??
This sucks so much!!
So click- There's a video
Probably on Wade's face. No, on my face.
Somewhere there's a video, it's here or there.
You can click to see the video right now.
Cinco De Pranko-It's almost over because it's
almost tomorrow.
It's stronger than it was before...
Ohhhh... This sucks
So expect more silliness coming in the future.
And as always-
It was my turn!
I didn't know! I thought I had to press it first before you did it
I'm not doing it anymore!
So anyway, thank you again everybody-
-for watching!
And as always, we will see you, in the next video.
How do we shock both of us?
Bye-Bye!
[Screams of agony]
Byeee! See yah!
That caught me off guard
It did, didn't it
Awww man.
I'm sweating so much
I know! That's what it did!
Like, when I did the thing, it caused me just to
sweat profusely. Like it's just unstoppable.
Why do you own this?
Wuhhh-For funnnn
So you and I can do these videos together.
A lot of fun
Yes....Fun
Wanna do it again?
Alright
Let's actually do it.
It will turn green, and whenever it turns green
whoever presses it first doesn't get shocked.
Alright
So there's high stakes on this one.
How long is it gonna go?
Random
Oh god
YES!
Why me?!
I pressed it!
Ow!
Owww. Right in the knee!
We both payed the price for you screwing up
Sucking dick all day long.
My hair is probably a mess.
Sucking dick, sucking dick,
Heigh-ho, Heigh-ho
It's off to suck we go.
Be sure to get the balls!
All over Donald Duck's face(?)